dark matter is the vast majority of a
mass of the entire universe it's the
mass that holds all galaxies together
and in fact led to the formation of
galaxies and it also holds clusters
together and it made the most important
contribution to the organization of the
structure of the universe we already
know that the dark matter is cold I
invented this terminology back in 1983
calling the dark matter hot warm or cold
depending on how rapidly it's moving in
the early stages of the Big Bang hot if
it's moving at nearly the speed of light
cold if it's moving so slowly that its
motion hardly matters and warm as an
intermediate case we know that the dark
matter has to be pretty cold but it
could be a little bit warm and that
would make a great difference to what we
call small scale structure the amount of
satellite galaxies and things like that
we don't yet know the real nature of the
dark matter beyond that it's pretty cold
being pretty cold is enough to allow us
to predict in great detail the
large-scale structure of the universe
the organization of the galaxies and to
some extent the satellites of the
galaxies but the small scale structure
of the universe really depends in more
detail on the nature of the dark matter
also the dark matter can possibly
interact with itself and annihilate and
two dark matter particles come together
and then make a lot of other stuff and
this could have played an extremely
important role in the early universe and
it could still be producing effects that
our sensitive detectors in space and on
the ground can come find experimentally
we haven't yet seen clear evidence for
any of these things although there are a
number of experiments that are reporting
tentative detections so it feels very
much like we're on the verge
of major breakthroughs in trying to
understand the nature of the dark matter
if we finally do figure out the nature
of the dark matter we will then have a
single unified picture of the origin and
evolution of the entire universe one
that scientists all over the world have
contributed to and that can become the
basis for a shared origin story that
could possibly solidify the bonds of
humankind we've never had a single
picture thoroughly supported by
scientific evidence and we're coming
close to it now so I think we scientists
are feeling very hopeful that we're
about to cross this threshold and have a
complete understanding of the origin and
evolution of the universe and of course
we're also coming to a much better
understanding of the evolution of life
so these last decades of the 20th
century in first decades of the 21st
century are a real turning point I think
and our understanding of how we got here